Salut, tout le monde !
J'espère que vous allez bien.
Alors, je suis super contente
de vous montrer ce documentaire
que j'ai réalisé pour BrutX
il y a quelques mois.
Vous allez découvrir une histoire
qui m'a beaucoup touchée,
que je voulais vous raconter.
En fait, je me suis toujours demandé
pourquoi certaines personnes s'engageaient
à 18 ou 20 ans dans l'armée
et qu'est-ce qui les motivait à partir
faire la guerre à l'autre bout du monde
pour une cause qui, parfois,
paraît un peu lointaine.
Alors, j'ai rencontré Théo,
qui va répondre à toutes ces questions
dans le documentaire.
Et en fait, je tourne avec lui au Mali,
quelques jours à peine
après un événement super traumatisant.
Il a perdu trois amis là-bas, sur place.
Alors, je tenais à vous dire quand même
que la situation au Mali
a pas mal changé depuis.
Les forces françaises sont
en ce moment même en train de partir du pays.
Ce sont donc quasiment les dernières
images de l'armée française là-bas.
Pour info, sur ma chaîne YouTube,
je vous raconte les coulisses de ce tournage.
Je vous mets le lien en description.
En attendant, je vous laisse
regarder le documentaire
qui s'appelle 28 décembre
et on se retrouve en fin de vidéo.
- Attends une minute.
Il faut le...
(Il tousse.)
(Il expire.)
(Musique de tension)
(Il souffle.)
Je pensais pas que j'étais
touché aussi à ce point-là.
En toute honnêteté.
Il faut que la population française
sache que...
ce qu'on vit ici,
c'est quand même dur.
(...)
- Trois nouveaux soldats français
morts en opération au Mali.
- Trois jeunes soldats
arrivés au Mali
il y a seulement un mois.
(...)
- C'est un engin artisanal,
une mine,
tout simplement,
qui a explosé sur leur passage.
Nouvelle histoire tragique,
qui endeuille
cette opération Barkhane,
c'est environ cinquante morts.
La vocation d'un soldat,
c'est d'aller au combat,
mais pas de mourir à vingt ans.
- Non, non, c'est bon.
- Y a pas de souci.
- Non, c'est bon. Je peux continuer.
(...)
Je suis le brigadier Théo.
J'ai vingt ans.
En mars, ça va faire
deux ans que je suis à l'armée.
Ça va ?
- Tranquille.
- Bien, ou quoi ?
- Ça va. La forme ?
- Hein ? Ah ben attends.
Marre-toi, marre-toi, marre-toi.
- Bon...
Repos. Bonjour à tous.
J'espère que vous avez bien dormi,
profité de ce réveil
un peu plus naturel que d'habitude.
Je tiens à vous alerter
de rester concentrés
jusqu'à la fin de la mission.
La mission n'est pas terminée.
Méfiez-vous.
On est dans une zone,
dans un territoire hostile,
où tout peut très vite déraper.
(Musique de tension)
- C'étaient comme des grands frères.
Ils étaient plus vieux que moi.
(Musique pesante)
Je les ai connus
dès mon entrée à l'escadron
et au peloton.
Depuis que je suis à l'armée,
j'ai tout fait avec eux.
Donc, ouais, c'est...
C'étaient des frères, ouais.
(...)
Pauchet avait un an de plus que moi.
Il avait vingt-et-un ans.
Issakhanian en avait vingt-quatre,
et le maréchal des logis Mauri
en avait vingt-huit.
(...)
On était très proches,
surtout
avec les deux premières classes,
Pauchet et Issakhanian.
Avec Issakhanian,
on était collègues de chambre
au régiment,
on était tout le temps ensemble.
C'étaient des... des super gars.
Des super gars, ouais.
(Message radio)
(Musique de tension)
(Hélicoptère)
(Résonnement aigu)
Le vingt-huit décembre,
on était tous partis en convoi.
L'aller s'est très bien passé
et on a réussi à y aller
en six-sept heures,
alors que les autres,
précédemment,
l'avaient fait en treize heures.
On est partis très tôt, le matin.
Y avait presque personne,
c'était quasiment désert.
C'était entre guillemets bizarre,
mais ça nous a pas tilté
tout de suite.
Les trois quarts des véhicules
passent.
(Une radio grésille.)
Et on entend un bruit bizarre,
à la radio.
Un espèce de... Un grésillement.
(...)
Tout de suite, on s'est retournés.
Et puis, on a vu un espèce de...
de grand nuage...
Un grand nuage de fumée,
avec une grosse poussière noire
et une boule de feu.
Et là, on s'est dit :
"Waouh, non, c'est pas possible."
(Musique pesante)
(...)
- Ouais, il est chaud.
- Il est showtime.
- Y en a marre...
(Rires)
- J'ai eu six à l'écrit au bac.
Du coup, c'est...
C'est tendu.
- Je suis pas allé au bac,
je rirai pas.
- Là, c'est écrit :
"marche à bestiaux".
- "Marché".
- Ça peut être ER ou un accent.
- C'est accent.
- Accent ?
- C'est "Des chiffres
et des lettres", là.
- On va débuter le "rehearsal"
pour la mission de demain,
c'est pas une balade.
On fait très attention.
Ce qui doit éveiller
notre attention :
les triporteurs,
les SUV pick-up et les motos,
OK ?
Il faut être très fermes.
Très fermes.
La situation générale dans la ville
de Gossi est inchangée.
Alpha, situation ennemie.
Ennemi global, qui chercherait
à mener une ou des attaques
d'opportunité,
afin de gêner notre action.
Y a pas d'autres questions ?
OK, j'en ai terminé.
Demain matin,
formation de la rame à 7h30,
façade nord.
Contrôle radio à 7h45.
Bon après-midi.
(Musique pesante)
(...)
- J'ai toujours voulu faire ça.
Au début, c'était plus
pour faire "la guerre",
comme dans les films.
J'ai toujours été fasciné par...
Par l'armée,
depuis le plus jeune âge.
J'ai eu un grand-père
qui était à l'armée aussi,
armée de l'air.
Mais lui, il était contre l'armée.
Mon père ne voulait pas non plus.
Ils ont une mauvaise image
de l'armée,
comme si on envoyait les hommes
au casse-pipe
tout le temps,
pour pas grand-chose, quoi.
Depuis que j'ai intégré l'armée,
je n'ai plus de contact
du côté paternel.
Ça fait beaucoup
de problèmes au sein de la famille,
d'ailleurs.
(Tonalité)
(...)
(Bip)
(Il rit.)
*- Coucou !
- Ça va ?
*- Ça va, et toi ?
T'as passé une bonne nuit ?
T'as bien récupéré ?
- Oui, ça va.
Ça va, ça va.
Oui, j'étais pas très bien...
J'avais un peu...
J'étais un peu patraque hier.
Le chat, il va bien ?
*- Le chat va bien.
(Rires)
- Il fait pas de conneries ?
*- Il t'attend avec impatience.
- Oui...
- Pas trop inquiète,
depuis l'accident ?
*- Si, très inquiète.
*C'est pour ça que quand il me dit
qu'il va sortir,
*c'est assez difficile, quoi.
*La seule chose que je souhaite
quand il part,
*c'est de pas avoir de nouvelles :
pas de nouvelles, bonnes nouvelles.
*C'est difficile. C'est difficile.
*Mais bon, il faut faire avec.
C'est son choix, donc...
C'est son choix,
donc c'est le mien aussi.
- Je te rappelle demain,
demain soir, après la mission.
*- Ouais.
- Ouais.
*- OK.
- OK.
*- Allez...
- Au revoir !
*- Au revoir !
- Bisous !
(Musique de tension)
(...)
Je vous cache pas que chaque fois
que je rentre dans...
dans ce véhicule,
je repense à ce 28 décembre.
Forcément, on y pense.
On y pense tout le temps.
Mais c'est pas...
(Communication radio)
(...)
(Détonation)
(Sifflement continu)
(...)
Il y a eu...
Il y a eu une espèce
de contrôle radio,
qu'on fait d'habitude,
et il y a eu une patrouille
qui n'a pas répondu.
(Musique de tension)
Vu qu'on était de tête,
on est arrivés très vite
à proximité du lieu,
de la zone de l'incident.
On a essayé de voir
s'il y avait un mouvement de vie,
savoir s'ils bougeaient,
s'ils étaient conscients,
s'il y avait pas de problème.
Donc on s'était dit :
"C'est bon, ils ont été amochés,
mais ils sont en vie."
Ah, j'ai chaud, là.
- C'est le stress ?
- Je crois que je suis malade.
Pour de vrai.
Je crois que j'ai la chiasse.
-Quand on vit ça la première fois,
ouais, c'est un peu...
Les gens, ils réalisent
un peu plus le danger de...
Que le métier...
On n'est pas peintres.
Je parle pour Théo,
il est tout jeune,
il profite pas de sa jeunesse.
Il a décidé de venir à l'armée,
peut-être pour...
S'il a des frères, des sœurs,
des copains,
qu'ils continuent
à vivre normalement,
faire leur vie normale,
sans se soucier des problèmes
qu'il peut arriver à l'étranger.
- Quand on est jeune,
on se rend pas compte
du sacrifice qu'on fait.
En tout cas,
je m'en rends pas vraiment compte.
Je m'en rends pas compte du tout.
- On a pas un corps pare-balles.
Malheureusement, des fois,
des gens nous quittent
plus tôt que prévu.
Il faut que les jeunes,
quand ils s'engagent,
en aient conscience.
- Oui.
(Musique pesante)
(...)
- Eh, souriez, là !
Vous êtes photographiés !
- Montre l'exemple !
(Rires)
- Allez, sergent !
Ça fait à peu près un an
qu'on se prépare bien,
avec plein d'exercices
qui nous mettent en situation,
face à des forces adverses,
fictives, bien sûr,
mais qui nous entraînent,
et qui sont...
bien poussées.
Je suis assez serein
pour partir.
- Il est quelle heure, là ?
- Il est 9h01.
- On va aller prendre l'apéro ?
-Aide-les... Théo, à...
- Vous êtes prêt à vous sacrifier,
justement, pour l'armée ?
- Prêt, on verra...
Certainement que je suis prêt.
Après, il faut voir,
en fonction du moment.
On n'est jamais forcément
prêt pour mourir.
On esquive, parce qu'on a du mal
à parler un peu de la mort.
En étant jeune,
c'est quelque chose de...
Enfin, ça nous paraît
un peu irréel.
Et...
(Musique pesante)
- Théo !
- Oui, Monsieur !
- Avec votre téléphone,
vous nous avez filmés ?
- On peut voir votre téléphone ?
- Le téléphone. Le téléphone.
- Celui-là ?
- Celui-là.
- Là. Ouais.
Je peux avoir
votre identité aussi ?
(...)
(Klaxon)
(Musique pesante)
(Brouhaha de conversations)
(Klaxon)
- Parfois, t'as peur,
quand tu patrouilles à pied ?
- Je dirais pas
que c'est de la peur,
mais c'est un stress...
Un gros stress.
Parce que...
Il y a du mouvement partout.
Et d'un coup,
c'est très dur de prévoir
quelqu'un qui déboule
de nulle part et...
probablement,
qui peut nous tirer dessus.
(Une radio grésille.)
(Détonation)
(Sifflement continu)
(...)
Quand on les a amenés
dans l'hélicoptère,
ils étaient déjà...
Ils étaient déjà partis...
sans qu'on ait pu rien faire.
Ils étaient morts directement,
sur le coup.
C'est un moment très dur.
Mais on était contents pour eux
qu'il y ait une belle cérémonie,
à leur égard.
(Il s'éclaircit la voix.)
- C'était la première fois
que tu voyais la mort ?
- Euh...
D'être confronté à la mort,
comme ça, oui.
C'était direct et violent.
(Musique douce)
C'est un peu nos trois étoiles,
qui nous surveillent,
qui nous protègent.
Nos anges gardiens.
(...)
- Sur le coup, on n'a pas
une envie de vengeance ?
(...)
- Euh... Sur le coup, si,
on a envie de tout casser.
On a envie de choper
le premier ennemi qui passe
et de lui mettre la misère.
Ça, c'est...
un sentiment qui a été
longtemps en nous.
Mais il faut quand même
faire preuve de...
De jugement, et d'être sûr
que ce soit un ennemi,
et qu'on ne fasse pas
de dommages collatéraux.
Ralentis un peu.
Coupe le moteur.
T'as une pièce d'identité ?
(Bips de touches)
- Bonjour. Merci.
Vous allez acheter quoi ?
- Je vais acheter quoi ?
- Oui.
- Je viens pour ma boutique.
- Ah OK. Elle est juste là-bas ?
- Oui, tout près ici.
Le camion, là,
qui est en train d'arriver.
- Est-ce qu'on est toujours le même
après ça ?
- Euh... forcément, non,
on n'est pas le même.
On change littéralement.
On prend plus conscience que la vie
est quelque chose de très précieux.
On se rend compte que
les petites choses du quotidien,
c'est... c'est très important.
C'est quelque chose d'incroyable.
Du coup,
on change profondément, déjà,
sur notre vision de vie.
- Bonjour.
- Vous étiez sur les barbelés ?
- Ouais, mais moi, je veux rentrer.
C'est lui qui va sortir.
- Du coup...
Tu rentres...
- Oui, je vais rentrer d'abord.
- OK.
- Ça vous manque pas,
les filles, pendant quatre mois ?
(Rires)
- Ah ben...
Si, ça manque quand même,
forcément.
- Ah ! D'accord !
- Y a quelqu'un qui t'attend ?
- Non, y a personne qui m'attend.
(Communication radio)
*- Charlie huit...
*Charlie huit.
- Base, ici, Charlie neuf.
Mise en place effectuée, RAS.
*- Charlie neuf, reçu.
- Là, on est bien.
Là, je suis dans le Charlie.
Là, c'est notre tour de garde.
Et du coup,
on doit surveiller l'extérieur,
s'assurer que personne de suspect
ne dépasse la digue.
- Ça va ?
- Ça va !
J'ai rien pour vous !
- Y a pas de rations.
Y a rien pour toi !
Je peux pas partir, moi. Non...
(Musique de tension)
(...)
Le pire, c'est la nuit.
C'est tout noir...
On voit que dalle.
Y a vite fait les ânes...
et les chèvres qui passent.
Dès qu'il y a une idée
qui nous passe par la tête,
on y pense... jusqu'au bout,
jusqu'à temps qu'une autre idée
nous passe par la tête.
Dès qu'il y a un bruit, on y pense.
Dès qu'il y a une lumière,
un truc...
ça nous éveille.
Un souvenir ou un truc comme ça,
on se fait mal au crâne tout seul.
(Sifflement diffus)
(...)
Des fois, on pense à rien,
et ça passe tout seul.
Et après, voilà. Tout ça s'en va.
Ça s'en va... Ça revient.
C'est que ça.
(Musique douce)
(...)
- Cinquante-deux.
- Tu paniques.
- Ah oui. Hier, c'était chaud.
- Oui, forcément.
Faut pas qu'on se laisse non plus
emporter dans une spirale...
de dépression et de tristesse,
sinon...
on n'arriverait plus à vivre
et on...
On serait tout le temps abattus.
Il faut continuer à vivre pour eux,
continuer de rigoler...
tout en pensant à eux,
en parlant...
en se rappelant des histoires
avec eux, des situations marrantes
qu'on a pu connaître avec eux,
ensemble.
C'est très important, toujours,
de rigoler ensemble.
Ça permet de garder
une force morale importante.
Hein ?
- T'utilises des beaux mots,
"force morale".
- Vous avez vu, un peu ?
OK, je suis peut-être jeune...
- Le prochain mot à placer,
c'est "résilience".
- "Résilience" ?
- Tu sais ce que c'est ?
- C'est l'opération...
J'espère que ce documentaire vous a plu
et surtout que vous avez
appris des choses.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner,
à liker, à partager, à commenter.
Si ça vous intéresse,
j'ai aussi fait une vidéo coulisses
sur ce tournage sur ma chaîne
YouTube personnelle.
Je vous mets le lien juste en description.
Dans cette vidéo,
je vous raconte un petit peu
ce que Théo est devenu
depuis que je l’ai filmé,
comment j'ai réussi
à travailler avec l'armée française
et je vous dirai un petit peu plus, aussi,
où en est la situation
au Mali aujourd'hui.
Merci beaucoup d’être resté
jusqu'à la fin de cette vidéo.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt.
(Musique douce)
(...)
Sous-titrage : BLUE ELEMENTS